frauen und männer haben verschiedene
gehirn war alles klar oder
okay okay wir reden darüber
neben durch einen tee setzt euch freunde
der sonne wir kennen die stereotypen
frauen reden viel männer nichts frauen
sind empathischer ich verstehe dich
männer rational ich bestehen hatte
frauen können kein auto fahren männer
können nicht zuhören was stereotypen
stellen nie die realität klar sind alle
individuelle menschen die in keine
schublade passen aber wenn man
statistisch die massen betrachtet
verhalten sich frauen und männer
durchaus unterschiedlich gesellschaft
und kultur haben einen wesentlichen
einfluss darauf aber gibt es auch einen
biologischen grund für das
unterschiedliche verhalten
ich werde euch gleich etwas über die
hier strukturen von männern und frauen
erzählen aber damit wir uns auch
wirklich auf die wissenschaft
konzentrieren können müssen wir ganz
kurz über das ihr reden
die kontroverse sagen wir ich bin gut in
chemie
dann kann das umwelt bedingt sein sprich
ich wurde entsprechend erzogen ich wurde
gefördert gebildet ich habe mir sachen
angeeignet oder mein talent für chemie
ist genetisch also in meiner dna codiert
alles was genetisch ist damit wären wir
geboren alle eigenschaften die etwas mit
persönlichkeit oder intelligenz zu tun
haben sind sowohl von der umwelt als
auch von unseren genen geprägt darüber
habe ich bereits lang und breit in
unserem video zur erblichkeit von
intelligenz gesprochen trotzdem
analysieren sozialwissenschaftler oder
psychologen unsere umwelt also unsere
gesellschaft um nachzuvollziehen wie zb
gender unterschiede entstehen warum
sollte man da nicht ebenso schauen ob es
genetische unterschiede gibt weil solche
forschungsergebnisse leicht missbraucht
werden können beziehungsweise sie werden
missbraucht werden ziemlich sicher es
wird immer menschen geben die
gesellschaftliche entscheidungen treffen
möchten auf basis unserer biologie doch
wer das tut vereinfacht diese
hochkomplexe biologie so stark dass es
nicht mehr wissenschaftlich korrekt ist
doch gerade weil es so leicht
missverstanden ist finde ich es wichtig
dass dieses thema unter wissenschaftlern
und unter fans freunden kein tabu-thema
und dass wir es auch hier im kreise der
freunde der sonne und der freunde der
rationalen diskussionen besprechen und
zwar ohne aufgeregt und differenziert
also cherry lane basics das gehirn ist
ein faszinierendes oder es kann
verblüffende kognitive leistungen
vollbringen
doch eines seiner größten
herausforderung ist es sich selbst zu
verstehen und da verstehen wir noch so
einiges nicht unser gehirn besteht aus
neuronen also nervenzellen die feuern
elektrische signale und sie
kommunizieren untereinander durch
moleküle und juden unsere gedanken sind
nicht einfach
materie los sondern sie sind grund
biologisch alles psychologische ist auch
gleichzeitig biologisch es sind alles
zelluläre molekulare prozesse nur
verstehen wir unser gehirn hat einfach
noch nicht gut genug wenn ich mir eine
gehirnstruktur ansehe und ein neurologe
wäre dann könnte ich daraus nicht
ablesen welche gedanken dieses gehirn
produziert wir wissen nur dass das
zusammenhängt das gehirn ist außer dem
glastisch das bedeutet es bilden sich
unser leben lang neue verknüpfungen wenn
sie etwas neues lernen verändert sich
dadurch meine hier in struktur ich
zitiere the dinosaurs fbh 4 bei den
kölner des models im gehirn liegt also
die ursache für unser verhalten
doch durch unser verhalten wird uns
agieren wiederum fortlaufend verändert
daraus folgt jetzt etwas ziemlich
wichtig ist nämlich im gehirn ist
biologisch nicht dasselbe wie von natur
aus im gehirn kann biologisch sowohl
genetische als auch umwelt bedingt sein
okay was ist jetzt der unterschied
zwischen frauen und männern auf die
größe von zehn männer farm in der regel
größere gehirne als frauen
hier die ergebnisse aus der bisher
umfangreichsten studie auf diesem gebiet
die erst vor wenigen monaten
veröffentlicht wurde
in blaue seht ihr die größenverteilung
deren männer gehirne in rot die der
frauen gehen und das ist erst mal nichts
ungewöhnliches bei männer ja generell
größer sind als frauen früher war das
größere männer gehirn grund genug zur
annahme dass männer intelligenter sein
als frauen
heute wissen wir zwar dass das nicht
stimmt aber die sache mit der
gehirngröße ist gar nicht so trivial
denn mehr hirnmasse bedeutet auch mehr
neuronen es ist nicht ganz ersichtlich
was die männer mit ihren extra neuronen
machen experten streiten sich jedenfalls
darüber wie man absolute und relative
schieren masse am sinnvollsten
interpretiert vielleicht wird man etwas
schlauer wenn man sich einzelne
gehirnregionen anschaut ihr paradies aus
derselben studie die meisten hier in
regionen sind bei männern
ebenfalls größer ihr müsst diese grafik
so viel stehen alles was blau gefärbt
ist das ist bei männern größer als bei
frauen alles was rosa gefärbt das ist
bei frauen größer als bei männern
und je kräftiger die farben desto größer
der unterschied volumen und oberfläche
ist jetzt in den meisten hirnregionen
bei männern größer als bei frauen
dafür haben frauen an einigen stellen
einen dickeren kortex der cortex ist die
äußere schicht des gehirns so viel zu
den absoluten werden teilt man jetzt
diese werte durch die gesamtgröße des
aliens betrachte man also relative größe
dann wären die unterschiede nicht nur
geringer also ihr seht die farben werden
vier blasser sondern sie kehren sich
teilweise sogar um
es macht also einen großen unterschied
wie man diese daten auswertet also hat
man absolute oder relative größen
vergleicht aber die eine spannende frage
ist doch was sagt das ganze über die
funktionalität aus größe allein sagt uns
jetzt noch nicht viel aber es gibt da
was anderes verschiedenen vernetzt man
kann sich das gehirn wie ein netzwerk
vorstellen und heutzutage kann man
messen wie stark verschiedene regionen
miteinander vernetzt sind wieder selber
studie anderes experiment ihr seht hier
verschiedene in ihren regionen und die
verbindungen zeigen euch an wie stark
diese regionen miteinander vernetzt sind
auch hier heißt blau dass die
verknüpfung bei männern stärker ist als
bei frauen
roth andersrum hier ist die verknüpfung
bei den frauen stärker und die kräftiger
die farbe desto größer der unterschied
zwischen den beiden geschlechtern mit
knüpfen die forscher an diese studie aus
dem jahr 2013
er wurde beobachtet dass männer hier
stärker innerhalb der hier in hälften
vernetzt sind hier dargestellt mit
blauem vernetzungen frauen hier hingegen
eine stärkere vernetzung zwischen den
hirnhälften haben hier dargestellt mit
orangenen vernetzungen in früheren
studien ließen sich bei frauen bessere
sprachliche und soziale fähigkeiten
messen bei männern bessere motorische
fähigkeiten und räumliches denken doch
ist das jetzt
ein neurologischer beweis für diese
unterschiede
allein diese fragestellung wurde von
kritikern der studie von anderen
fachexperten als neuro sexistische
bezeichnet wer hätte gedacht dass
science sowie drummer hat ich das ganze
einordne werde ich euch gleich noch
ausführlich erzählen aber vorher müssen
wir uns noch eine sache klar machen
typisch mann typisch frau oder typisch
im durchschnitt markus unterschiede
geben aber mit ausnahme von der
absoluten hier in größe gibt es bei
allen merkmalen größere überschneidungen
als unterschiede quantitativ gesprochen
haben männer und frauen mehr gemeinsam
als sie unterscheidet ich meine wir sind
alle eine homo sapiens was erwartet man
auch außerdem ist jeder mensch in seiner
persönlichkeit natürlich hoch
individuell das zeigt auch diese studie
hier hier wird nämlich männer und frauen
nicht als eine große kurve jeweils
zusammengefasst sondern die
forscherinnen schauten sich jeden
teilnehmer individuell an um
herauszufinden ob es prinzipiell zwei
arten von gehirn gibt ein männliches und
ein weibliches die wissenschaftlerinnen
konzentriert sich auf bestimmte merkmale
wie zum beispiel die größe bestimmte
hirnregion sie wählten sich um die zehn
merkmale aus und zwar diejenigen bei
denen die unterschiede zwischen männern
und frauen am größten war und jedes
merkmal bezeichneten sie das eine
extreme drittel als typisch männlich und
das andere extreme drittel als typisch
weiblich und alles dazwischen als nicht
so nen also also weder besonders
männlich noch weiblich dann erstellten
sie drei verschiedene ihren kategorien
erstens ein typisch männliches oder
typisch weibliches hier ein typisch
männliches hier besitzt nur typisch
männliche merkmale neben mich merkmalen
zweitens mischen mischen besitzen nur
mit merkmale sind also generell nicht
besonders typisch für das ein oder
andere geschlecht und drittens mosaik
ihren musik besitzen
sowohl typisch männliche als auch
typisch weibliche merkmale
dann schauten sie sich individuelle
menschen an und ordneten jeden menschen
in einer dieser drei ihren kategorien
ein die forscherinnen werteten
unterschiedliche datensätze aus und
dabei stellten sie fest je nach
datensatz hatten gerade mal 0 bis 8
prozent der probanden ein typisches
gehirn also ein typisch weibliches oder
typisch männliches gegen ein
wesentlicher teil nämlich je nach
datensatz 23 bis 53 prozent hatten
mosaik und der rest hatte mich hier
diese studie wurde in den fachkreisen
von manchen gelobt sorgte aber auch für
viel aufruhr es gab mehrere öffentliche
und schriftliche auseinandersetzungen
statements replies drama ich habe mir
natürlich eine tüte popcorn geschnappt
und mir das ganze drama aufmerksam
durchgelesen und bei mancher war wieder
kritik bleibt am ende der schluss so
etwas wie ein menschliches gehirn und
ein weibliches gehirn scheint es nicht
zu geben
wissenschaft richtig ein all das ist
bisher nur grundlagenforschung die
versucht unterschiede festzustellen und
nicht sie zu erklären und schließlich
sprechen wir hier nur von einzelnen
features des gehirns von größen
verschiedener regionen von der art und
weise wie sie miteinander verknüpft sind
das alles beschreibt noch lange nicht
das gehirn in seiner vollständigkeit
geschweige denn gedanken verhalten
fähigkeiten die daraus entstehen
beispiel sagen wir ich entwickle ein
neues medikament im labor und dieses
medikament ist wirksam in einem zelt ist
dann ist das war eine super nachricht
aber ich muss dann trotzdem noch sehr
viel mehr erzählt tests machen und
tierversuche und klinische studien zu
diesem zeitpunkt würde niemand auf die
idee kommen dieses medikament direkt auf
den markt zu bringen richtig wichtig und
genauso wenig sollte man biologische
grundlagenforschung in der
gesellschaftlichen praxis auf gender
diskussionen anwenden aber warum
erforscht man das ganze dann überhaupt
gute frage die gelenk krankheit arthrose
ist bei frauen deutlich häufiger als bei
männern
ein zeichen dafür dass biologische
unterschiede zwischen frauen und männern
über die unterschiedlichen
geschlechtsorgane und sexualhormone
hinausgehen frauen leiden häufiger an
alzheimer depressionen und
angststörungen männer seien häufiger an
autismus schizophrenie und legasthenie
es kommt auch immer mal wieder vor dass
medikamente wieder vom markt genommen
werden müssen weil in der breiten
anwendung nebenwirkungen auftreten die
man vorher nicht erwartet hat sehr oft
sind diese nebenwirkungen für frauen
riskanter als für männer 2013 musste die
amerikanische arzneimittelbehörde die
dosierung für das schlafmittel ambien
runter regulieren die zugelassene dosis
ist jetzt für frauen gerade mal halb so
groß wie für männer
weil der wirkstoff bei frauen langsamer
verstoffwechselt so dass sie leichter
überdosieren es gibt die vermutung dass
das problem bereits im labor bei der
medikamentenentwicklung anfängt genauer
gesagt all den tierversuchen die meisten
tierversuche sind um aus versuche und
sehr oft arbeitet man lieber mit
männlichen versuchs tieren als mit
weiblichen weibliche labormäuse haben
ein win situation zyklus von ungefähr
einer woche und bei diesem ganzen
hormonhaushalt ist es eben nicht ganz so
einfach systematischer experimente
durchzuführen ist es also ein
medizinischer fehler dass männliche und
weibliche gehirn als biologisch gleich
zu behandeln
es ist zumindest ein ernstzunehmendes
risiko das meiner meinung nach erforscht
werden sollte aufgeklärt aufgeregt ich
finde es so gut
dass ihr dazu bereit seid nicht den
einfachsten weg zu gehen dass ihr nicht
vor komplexität zurückschreckt und dass
ihr euch so ein video bis hierhin
anschaut hier seid wahres 1 freund wahre
freunde der sonne
deshalb freue ich mich darauf eure
kommentare zu lesen denn ich weiß dass
diese community dazu in der lage ist
unaufgeregt und sachlich zu diskutieren
über ein grund wissenschaftliches thema
das der dann zur kontroverse wird wenn
man die wissenschaft über geht indem man
zu sehr vereinfacht oder voreilige
schlüsse zieht
alle die jetzt noch da sind können auch
noch gleich mitkommen in die and car
wenn ihr echte freunde der sonne seid
habt ihr wahrscheinlich gemerkt dass ich
eine woche länger sommerpause genommen
habe als angekündigt weil einfach so wie
bei mir loser und ich diese woche
gebraucht habe damit ich ab jetzt wieder
geilen content liefern kann und ich bin
zurück ich freue mich und ich bin auch
wieder zurück bei social media
da habe ich eigentlich auch eine art
pause gemacht ich war sehr wenig online
die letzten wochen das war auch ganz
schön aber ab jetzt könnt ihr mir auch
wieder folgen es lohnt sich wieder bis
hin zur nächsten donnerstag bis dahin
bleibt sicher